have you been watching Casey's videos  since he's been back in New York no have  you yeah I watched a few did you watch  his videos like back when he was daily  oh 100 right but now that I'm friends  with him in person like I know his  his like mannerisms in the way that he  speaks what you know him in person  just had to slide that one in you know  now I'm best  you are also friends with him are you  not yeah but I didn't have to tell  everyone you just said you were flying  to South Africa yeah but it didn't go  yeah via Casey you know now that we're  friends  I'm just saying I surf I just  I'm just saying his his mannerisms  remind me  [Music]  I was if you would let me finish I was  gonna say his mannerisms remind me a lot  of post Malone who we're also friends  with  [Laughter]